solar systems follow a pretty generic
recipe to begin combine hydrogen helium
oxygen and carbon into a cloud of gas
and dust sprinkle with magnesium iron
and silicon spin it until the cloud
forms star and a planetary disk wait 10
million years or until lumps form in the
disk and voila you've baked a solar
system the planets we found orbiting
other stars are very different from the
ones in our own solar system
so the recipes for cooking up an
exoplanet are probably pretty different
from those for baking in Earth ok so
you've got a star it contains a list of
all the chemical ingredients that a
planet has to work with those
proportions vary from planet to planet
and astronomers are still trying to
figure out what factors produce a rocky
planet versus a gassy water mixing
matters - some planetary discs are more
turbulent than others and where
different elements end up in the mix
determines whether or not they end up in
the planet when a planet forms also
makes a big difference gas giants need a
lot of prep time they have to form a
rocky core before they can start
collecting vapors so they start baking
soon after their star forms small rocky
planets will start later how far a
planet forms in relation to its star
complicates planetary recipes small
planets that form too close to a star
can lose their atmospheres to energetic
winds from the star sometimes big
planets may arise of the system's edges
but finish cooking closer to their star
later on that's one way to make oddballs
like hot versions of Jupiter or Neptune
scientists are studying exactly how
these variables influence planet
formation in other systems and NASA's
latest planet hunting satellite tests
could reveal clues to exotic exoplanet
compositions meanwhile researchers are
cooking up experimental planets in the
lab to try to understand how other
systems formed so one day faking an
exoplanet will be a piece of cake
[Music]
[Music]